[Musique]
e
messieurs bonjour nous vous recevrons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle singer view on aurait aimé
avoir un petit peu votre expérience sur
l'actualité sur des sujets de fond on va
commencer par vous présenter à ma gauche
nous avons hervé brusini qui a été
rédacteur en chef du journal de france 2
deux fois de suite deux fois deux ans la
dernière fois vous avez quitté c'était
en 2011 vous êtes actuellement directeur
du site france télé point info et vous
avez reçu le prix albert londres pour
d'affaires farwell mois un dossier sur
farwell nous avons à notre centre pierre
connaissent à l'ancien des affaires
stratégiques qui a passé un petit peu
sur la vente d'armes des choses comme ça
et d'aider expertise au niveau du
moyen-orient et nous avons un autre à
droite eric filiol qui est directeur
d'un laboratoire de virologie que deux
géants informatiques qui est ancien
officier la dgse messieurs bonjour
pierre connaît ça bonjour comment on en
est arrivé là les attentats de paris
et toute cette folie autour de la
ceinture méditerranéenne
le brave on peut remonter assez loin
mais enfin bon on va essayer de la faire
brève
il faut il faut évidemment reprendre la
chose au moins au moment de ceux de
cette erreur stratégique gigantesque qui
a été nerveuse en irak par les
néoconservateurs américains
c'est explicatif de deux choses d'abord
le fait il ya un mouvement il ya une
espèce de idéologie politique qui
aujourd'hui malheureusement très
répandue en france il ya peu le néo
conservatisme et qui pense que on peut
redessiner la carte du globe par des
moyens militaires et de la point
d'application de cette politique ça a
été la vision de l'irak et l'invasion de
l'irak a donc commencé lama générer une
pagaille absolument extraordinaire sur
cet espace géographique
et puis ensuite il ya eu le choc des
révolutions arabes qui s'était répandue
en syrie donc on a une espèce de
dialectique où il ya les dynamiques
internes de systèmes et puis les
dynamiques externe des décideurs
occidentaux qui continue à considérer
que le l'espace moyen-orientale est un
espèce de terrain de jeu pour nos
militaires puisqu'ils passent leur temps
à envoyer des militaires partout père
vue
moi je pense que c'est la première fois
que j'arrive à la télé c'est le dire et
le massacre de la rue des rosiers et là
on était dedans une devant une
composante palestinienne qui était celle
d'abou nidal sinistre personnage
et
je me souviens qu'à l'époque on était en
mal d'expliquer les choses
le journalisme était convoqué à la
nécessité de faire une pédagogie de la
situation
et là il a fallu ouvrir un peu les
livres d'histoire se remuer et pas
simplement faire la revue de la violence
et c'est là que la première fois moi je
mange je n'avais pas croisé ça en classe
j'ai vu cette expression qui est les
accords sykes picot d'ailleurs ce truc
des années de postes première guerre qui
dessine la carte du moyen-orient est
très souvent c'était écrit à quel point
c'était quand même assez artificiel et
donc je pense que de 2
depuis cette époque nous ne cessons de
payer
une situation géopolitique
qui a été
comment dire une duperie c'est ce qui
explique je trouve assez remarquablement
luizard dans un livre s'appelle le piège
des ch qui est qu' on a fait croire à
beaucoup de des populations locales que
on allait célébrer une sorte de grande
unité arabe et on s'est ingénié à faire
tout le contraire et c'est ce que disait
pierre c'est à dire qu'il ya
effectivement 7 ce rapport très
militaire très c'est nous qui décidons
en votre place et quelque part l'astuce
de neige c'est de dire c'est nous les
vrais représentants de des aspirations
qui sont les vôtres et donc faut nous
rejoindre ça passe à la fois par la mise
en l'air des frontières qui ont été
dessinés ils ont fait ça en 2014 coup de
bulldozer
pour montrer que voilà cet ancien ordre
n'était plus valable et bien sûr le le
califat et tous avec une violence
absolue parce que ces populations en
même temps n'aspirais pas vraiment à ça
directement mais néanmoins garder ce
souvenir fort d'une identité arabe
vérifie les rôles
je penche surtout la conséquence est le
résultat d'une méconnaissance totale des
cultures et surtout l'idée
qu'il existerait qu'un seul modèle le
nôtre applicable à l'ensemble du monde
et justement c'est cette idée fausse
parce qu'elle s'inscrit dans une
méconnaissance d'ignorance crasse de ce
que sont les cultures alors qu'heuliez
pendant alors le mot a peut-être choquer
les pans de 100 ans d'expérience
coloniale on avait des militaires qui au
contraire
s'adapter aux cultures locales les
comprenez est finalement et c'est tout
un compromis qui était en faveur
d'ailleurs des populations locales on
est passé à un modèle
très centré sur l'europe et sur le
modèle du ray en glace action en pensant
que ce modèle unique et force est
valable pour tout le monde et doit
s'imposer à tout le monde or quand on
connaît bien les cultures et c'est
justement le
un problème actuel c'est qu'on ne
comprend plus laisser culture art
qu'elle soit 2 de cette région là mais
en général dans d'autres parties du
monde et en fait c'est une faillite de
cette vision pire comme ça
je crois que l'essentiel a été dit c'est
à dire effectivement ce rapport de
domination intellectuelle et politique
que l'occident à l'époque c'était les
français les anglais puis après ça les a
compris la suite qui fait qu' on n'a
cessé de prendre des décisions à la
place des auteurs de la région polar
bien donc il ya effectivement les
accords sykes picot il ya eu la
tradition trahison de
lawrence d'arabie a subie quand on prône
était une grande nation arabe qui
finalement ne s'est pas fait il ya eu le
fait que même dans le pacte du quincy
quand le roosevelt rencontres in saudi
lui dit promet qu' effectivement il y
aura pas de création de l'état d'israël
sans qu'ils soient consultés évidemment
il se fera sans sucre sans le consulter
il ya tout si vous levez cette espèce de
prise de décision continue qui fait que
les occidentaux ont géré la région
al'avantage moyens un exemple qui est
absolument prodigieux qui est celui du
11 septembre dans lequel on a 15
saoudiens sur 19 terroristes et par un
tour de passe-passe fantastique qui
prouve d'ailleurs l'affluence à revers
de certains pays de la région sur les
décideurs george bush décide que l' axe
du mal c'est l'iran l'irak et la corée
du nord trois pays dont ne venait au
camp des terroristes et donc on est dans
cette espèce de méconnaissance ou en
tout cas de connaissances perfide de la
région et puis le fait que les décideurs
de la région eux-mêmes sont totalement
déconsidéré et c'est à dire aussi le
nationalisme arabe est mort assad est
quand même un effroyable dictateur et
messaoud et en espèces d'allumer enfin
yahoo la famille de la dynastie des le
roi d'arabie saoudite est une espèce de
comment dire de directeur d'asiles
psychiatriques qui en plus diffuse son
modèle à l'étranger donc on est dans une
situation fantastique parce que on va
battre contre des ch pour le défendre
l'arabie saoudite il ya un article du
new york times récemment qui est très
bien fait je malheureusement bien large
le nom de l'auteur c'est un
universitaire français il dit l'arabie
saoudite 20 dh qui a réussi voilà c'est
la formule est assez juste faire hervé
quand on voit que son commerce ont des
partenariats des contrats avec les
directeurs de l'asile psychiatrique
l'arabie saoudite comment les
journalistes se comporte par rapport à
ce type d'information
comment il se comporte
normalement
ils doivent enquêter et faire le travail
c'est plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît
en fait à travers cette question tu es
en train de me dire qu'est ce que vous
foutez oui surtout les doigts du cul oui
pour le coup
je pense qu'on on se l'est sort pas si
mal je sais que c'est honteux dire ça
aux yeux et aux oreilles de l'internet
joue de l'internet
l'idée c'est qu'on vient de loin c'est
un sujet très complexe après tout la
qualité de l'info la qualité du
journalisme à quoi tout cela se mesure
t-il
je disais que la première fois que je
suis confronté à la violence terroriste
en ce qui me concerne c'est la rue des
rosiers et donc à l'époque il y avait
aussi un terrorisme national
qui était action d'hier avec la corse le
pays basque
beaucoup de choses sur lesquelles
auxquelles j'ai été confrontée à chaque
fois il fallait comprendre ce qui était
en train de se passer travail et se
cultiver au sens plein du terme et il
fallait pas simplement dire regardez
tous ces morts et parfois même faire
tout l'historique des morts parce c'est
un certain moment nous ne faisions que
ça mais aller plus loin de ceux qui
consistait à expliquer d'où cela venait
quelle était la situation
qui est se cacher derrière un texte de
revendication
c'est un gros investissement et à la
télévision en particulier un
investissement je dirais même plus
globalement mais surtout elle avait eu à
la télé
c'est un investissement auquel le média
n'était pas franchement klein c'est à
dire de faire réellement une enquête de
fond longue
avec toute la toute l'implication que ça
suppose en termes de temps et de moyens
et donc il a fallu parce que ça s'est il
ya 30 ans 40 ans jouer des coudes pour
peu à peu imposé la simple dimension de
l'enquète à la télé qui n'allait pas de
soi cinq colonnes à la une
était une émission qui était
essentiellement du reportage pour voir
ce qui était en train de se passer
interwievé les grands acteurs du moment
mais la dimension d'une réelle enquête
n'était pas vraiment à l'ordre du jour
de cinq colonnes c'est pour ça qu'on a
vu les réseau gladio émergé en europe
bien sûr je sais pas si c'est pour ça
mais en tout cas nous n'avons pas été à
la hauteur des grands défis de
l'histoire qui se déroulait à ce moment
là c'est clair
parce que le je dirais le contrepoison
que peut représenter de l'info n'était
pas au rendez vous il était un peu en
cours d'élaboration
il ya des types qui se disait [__] il
faut qu'on le fasse qui des journalistes
des responsables de rédac ils ont sauté
pas forcément sont des gens qui ont pu
faire leur travail certains oui son je
dirais morts au champ d'honneur
eric
le traitement de l'information sur aulas
moi j'ai été j'ai eu quand j'étais
militaire j'ai été formé à l'otan sur
l'est ce qu'on appelle les techniques de
formation opération en gros ça c'est le
terme on va dire politiquement correct
en gros manipulation de l'information
c'était havrais en 2008 sauf qu on nous
apprenait comment sur un cadre
d'opérations il fallait présenter
l'information pour que les autorités
civiles et militaires les journalistes à
san jose gob globe les choses et bref sa
forme de choses pas forcément acceptable
le deviennent en fait ce que ce que je
vois actuellement quand je regarde la
télé comme je veux dire à la en étant
des deux côtés sur l'homme de la rue est
et en suivi cette formation je vois en
fin de compte que c'était aux libyens se
sont répandus partout et qu'on est
effectivement sur alors le mot est
peut-être un peu fort mais une forme de
censure qui dit pas son nom dans une
forme de manipulation des des individus
et je pense qu'en ce moment avec les
derniers les derniers événements elle
est encore à l'heure on l'a vu sur des
tas de questions notamment dans la
région du proche et moyen-orient bref on
est dedans il faut quand même appeler un
chat un chat renée sur des techniques de
manipulation pierre la propagande dans
challenges la propagande de guerre je
voudrais revenir à l'esprit la mise en
accusation des journalistes moi je mise
en accusation je vais revenir là dessus
parce que la formation de l'information
la formation de l'opinion si tu veux ce
n'est pas que les journalistes moi je
suis beaucoup plus sensibles à l'espèce
de silence extraordinaire des politiques
ou des administrations sur le sujet
parce que on a donné des leçons de
droits de l'homme à tout le monde sauf à
certains pays clients j'en ai en
particulier en tête mais qui fait qu' on
a absolument délivrer des brevets de
droits de l'homme allant depuis
l'extrême orient jusqu'à l'extrême sud
de l'amérique latine mais il y avait des
zones dans lesquelles on ne disait
jamais amour et ça ça contribue à la
formation au pire ensuite un deuxième
strate qui est celle de l'administration
c'est à dire comment est ce qu'on fait
une note pour un ministre comment on
fait une note sur un mini ce nom revient
jamais en arrière sur l'histoire du pays
c'est à dire on reprend la note
précédente on la met à jour et en lui
dit alors moi j'ai trouvé cette
argumentation très souvent sur les pays
du golfe c'est en gros ces gens là nous
sommes comme des fous d'ailleurs
regardez ils sont ils nous achètent des
armes ils nous achètent des tas de
choses etc et puis avec ce sentiment de
connaître la région puisqu'on y allait
souvent et quand on va souvent dans un
endroit mais qu on rencontre toujours
les mêmes personnes
on fait de la soviet au logis
c'est-à-dire endiablé me suis là je n'ai
vu la dernière fois mais il était entré
numéro trois par la porte alors que là
il est rentré numéro 2 donc il est monté
en grade témoin mais comprendre la
société comprendre ses motivations
par exemple on utilisait dans les
télégrammes diplomatiques des concepts
de côté d'ivoire celle et francophile et
francophone comme si le monde était
divisé en deux camps ceux où il y avait
des chantiers mais la france gens qui
met pas que les gens puissent être
nationaliste c'est à dire à certains
moments avoir des relations avec la
france d'une certaine nature et puis
changer de bord s'est passé concept là
qu'ils expliquent c'est de les
comprendre c'est le problème de la
culture c'est le problème de dire à tes
un temps par exemple janin l'ambassadeur
ne dira son ministre des affaires
étrangères vous savez votre opinion sur
la crise dans laquelle je suis tout le
monde s'en fout ici on va expliquer au
contraire au ministre que sa prise de
position est absolument essentiel parce
que la france membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité puissances
nucléaires en un seul mot tac tu as ta
conditionner le truc et cette formation
de l'opinion la cette formation de ses
élites se traduit dans la perception de
l'opinion donc les journalistes ils ont
l'avantagé de faire du terrain et a
jamais vu un homme politique sortir de
ce cercle dans lequel il va faire son
invitation pour aller voir à quoi
ressemble soupe pour aller voir
convention une décapitation sur une
place publique en arabie saoudite c'est
ça la réalité et donc moi je des douanes
les journalistes parce que cela il faut
lire et ajuste continuellement leurs
logiciels dans ce milieu dans lequel
chaque mois les militaires ont souvent
d'ailleurs la capacité à pouvoir dire
les choses simplement la question ces
commissions dans la grande muette je
n'écoute pas ils ont le devoir de
réserve et le problème c'est quand même
comprendre que je rejoins pierre soit là
sur le mutisme voir la cécité de nos
administrations mais faut comprendre ce
que c'est que l'administration française
notamment dans le domaine dans le
domaine régalien en gros pour un
exécutif on a un certain nombre de chefs
sous chef bandit on a un centre de gens
qui ne produisent rien les médiocres
éventuellement on va dire disons de
journaux productif ces gens là dans la
fonction publique ils doivent progresser
parce qu'ils sont réussite à ces rats et
autres et il ya un maître mot c'est
quand on ne fait rien on peut pas se
tromper donc on a une fossilisation à
différents niveaux 2 de gens qui au
compteur devrait parler les militaires
on leur reproche leur devoir de réserve
mais souvent ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut pas preuve d'initiative deux une
certaine liberté de parole dexia
n'engage pas la défense le prendre c'est
qu'ils sont très vite rappelé à l'ordre
faut quand même rappeler que depuis 1981
les généraux sont nommés par le pouvoir
politique non plus par les militaires ce
qui ce qui est une forme disons de
contrôle dit pas son nom mais
effectivement cette fossilisation cette
stratification à l'extrême
des entités gouvernementales et en
particulier des services de
renseignement fait que ben on est dans
une inertie totale moi j'ai vu je
connais souvent des cas ou à l'étranger
lors enseignement se fait dans les
cocktails se fait pas dans la médina se
fait pas dans l'est sur le terrain se
fait pas au contact des gens ça c'était
la culture coloniale troupes de marine
où on est on vivait avec les populations
et finalement chaque militaire est un
capteur et qui a renseigné mais le
problème du renseignement c'est vous
pouvez collecter autant de l'information
qu'on veut il faut qu'après les chefs
aient envie de l'écouter de le traiter
d'y croire il faut surtout pas que ça
vienne
déroger la vision préétabli donc il ya
des fois des choses qu'on met sur le
tapis pour revenir dans le sens de ce
que tu dis moi j'ai vécu un épisode
absolument cocasse j'étais en iran d'un
régis debray on va à rome la ville
sainte on aurait des ayatollahs avec qui
on discute enfin bon des types très
intelligent avec tout l'argumentaire
qu'on va les jésuites de le schisme et
puis il y avait dans l'eure la réunion
un français qui vit en iran depuis 79
que le type sont convertis au schisme
page anciens automatique il avait fait
sa thèse à l'époque sur la théologie de
bonheur khomeiny mais le système
universitaire française et matin et que
ça nous intéresse le des théologies trop
minime donc ce type s'est fixé là bas et
puis en dons qu'il était le meilleur
traducteur que le traducteur officiel
qui nous avait donné on revient à la
télé rend et on était invité le soir
chez l'ambassadeur alors il nous dit pas
ce que je peux venir avec vous on s est
dit fier de ce panneau qu'invite ans on
va pas te leur dire on a vu de la
lumière on est monté avec un copain donc
il n'y a pas et on arrive dans un dîner
dans lequel il y avait le prototype des
contacts continuent de tous les
ambassadeurs qui succède sur un poste
c'est à dire le francophone locale qui
est un pur produit de nos lycées
français de l'étranger et qui connaît
mieux la vie politique française que toi
et qui vient te parler de la vie
politique française alors que le type
intéressant c'était celui qui était
dehors c'était celui qui était justement
au contact de la sphère décisionnelle
iranienne mais celui là je pense que nos
services avaient dû dire ouh là là il
faut se méfier de lui parce que celui là
il vit là bas depuis longtemps donc il a
dû être tamponné il a dû être ouverte et
tu vois le truc et c'est ça le paradoxe
est que si un type est propre sur lui
qu'il est un produit des systèmes
français jean massoud il est
effectivement l'homme qu'il faut
contacter mais faire cet effort de se
dire le matin celui qu'on doit
comprendre c'est l'autre c'est l'ennemi
c'est celui qui pense exactement à
l'opposé de nous celui là on fait pas
les forces et les journalistes qu'ils
font c'est pas les politiques parfois
ils le font je le dis parce que voilà
c'est vrai au péril de leur vie
moi je suis du service public et
franchement on a payé cher en terme de
liberté et en termes de vies humaines et
donc ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
il n'ya pas d'un côté la pureté de
l'info et de l'autre côté la censure
c'est plus compliqué que ça parce que si
on s'attaquait à la censure et qu'on la
lève et à dieu ne plaise comme dirait
l'autre ça se fait quand même
dans notre quotidien jose ledit
l'autocensure attends je
parle de la censure en tant que tel
on pourrait donc à voir si
le truc était simplement duel avoir une
pureté de l'info et ce serait le nirvana
de la démocratie tous les jours or c'est
pas ça parce que l'info c'est un boulot
et donc c'est pas simplement une affaire
de on m'interdit de dire la vérité c'est
que cette vérité je dois travailler pour
la trouver la construire la l'élaborer
et la transmettre c'est un très grand
travail et c'est quelque chose dont on
doit prendre conscience comme étant un
élément
fondateur de la démocratie et du rôle
des journalistes en démocratie est donc
cet investissement lie cette prise de
conscience
encore une fois oui j'ose le dire depuis
30 ans ou 40 ans va grandissant sur les
antennes
s'agrandissant oui y compris dans les
journaux télévisés
il ay ay si elle a énormément d'infos
qui passe il y a dans les magazines
énormément d'informations qui passe il y
a plein de boîtes de prod et des gens à
l'intérieur des chaînes et je dis aussi
du service public a pris conscience
quand même du rôle qui est le sien de
défendre ce journalisme offensif tant
dans les émissions que pièces à
conviction cache où on voit bien qu'il
ya quand même quelque chose qui part à
l'assaut mais sa faune c'est tellement
peu c'est tellement pub c'est peu
pourquoi pourquoi je t'ai fait venir
aujourd'hui parce que tu as travaillé
pour quelque chose à cacher
investigations engagées jeu j'ai fait
pièce a coûté sa fonction je respecte
totalement les amis de première ligne
qu'ils font cash
et des tas d'autres émissions ou de
reportages des journaux là on va parler
du 20 heures c'est à dire le ce que tu
connais bien qu'est-ce qui fait la
discrimination par rapport aux 5000
dépêche de l afp tous les jours qui fait
le journal et comment ça se fait que
vous vous copier les uns les autres
c'est une grande question parce que on
ne téléphone pas j'ai essayé d'y
réfléchir j'ai essayé de faire un petit
bouquin là dessus pour comprendre parce
que cherche du sens à ce que j'ai pu
faire
dans une petite vie professionnelle et
ça m'emmerde
compose sans arrêt les mêmes questions
depuis 40 ans ou 50 ans sur les
journalistes se faisant passer quarante
ans c'est à dire depuis 40 ans on dit
qu'on est des pourris qu'on ait des
vents du conte et ceci qu'on est ce là
et ça ne progresse pas
ça ne fait pas avancer la chose alors
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour avancer
il faudrait comprendre ce qu'on est en
train de faire et comment ça marche par
exemple la question du dis que tu poses
pardon
pourquoi est ce que vous dites tous la
même chose d'abord je soutiens l'idée
que ça a été vrai mec ça l'est beaucoup
moins qu'auparavant
j'ai essayé d'analyser tous les dix ans
ce qu'était le fonctionnement médiatique
à une date qui devait tant d'octobre je
me souviens plus j'ai choisi une date
arbitraire j'ai vu que dans les années
50 60 70
une diversité considérable et au fur et
à mesure qu'on va vers les années quatre
vingt il ya une uniformisation du
discours journalistique
rien que ce petit travail
il est à mon avis à développer à savoir
ce qui s'est passé il faut que les
historiens s'en emparent
pour pour pour répondre à cette question
là qui est une question politique pour
moi de fonds et d'urgence parce que nous
sommes face à un point crucial y compris
pour en revenir à des ch
dans ce que nous vivons c'est une
défiance radical de ceux pour lesquels
on est en train de parler là sur youtube
de tout le web qui me confient mois le
journaliste ainsi que tous mes confrères
je pense que cette situation est
politiquement
épouvantable et qu'il faut que nous
retrouvions la confiance des personnes à
quel prix au prix de l'intelligence de
savoir ce que nous faisons
l'intelligence de ce que nous faisons
c'est déjà montré comment fonctionne
c'est à dire adopter une démarche de
transparence qui est un peu celle de
cash précisément c'est à dire quand je
cherche une info je vais trouver
quelqu'un et je lui pose des questions
il est d'accord pas d'accord mais le
journaliste a retrouvé droite cité dans
l'image tu vois par exemple et les
jeunes mecs que ce soit au petit journal
ou au 20h ou ailleurs on revoit les
journalistes à l'antenne il fut tout un
temps où les journalistes c'était
monsieur vous l'aof
on les avait perdus de vue à cinq
colonnes on savait qu'ils étaient les
mecs roger louis sur le terrain la
france entière le connaissais c'était un
reporter identifier je pense que le
gommage des journalistes dans à
l'antenne a été un des premiers facteurs
de de perte de confiance parce que
c'était plus un boulot c'était comme une
sorte de grande caméras de sécurité qui
se trimballait par le monde avec une
voix non identifié on te disait le grand
message
interplanétaire ça a concouru très
certainement a encore une fois perdre
les gens deuxième point une attitude qui
n'était plus celle de l'enquêteur mais
celle de l'examinateur pour moi de
l'info
examiné l'info c'est la problématique et
c'est commencer à rentrer dans une
manière de voir les choses qui est plus
de l'ordre du gouvernement des gens que
du questionnement journaliste résumé
trivialement ces passages de place c'est
passage de plats bien à la trivialité
pourquoi gare de triage et parce que la
trivialité parfois fait que tu
caricature un truc qui mérite beaucoup
mieux pour qu on y remédie un mec un
gros rhume le mec se pointe devant le
toubib elle toubib distingue gros rhume
en fait derrière le type se peignent un
cancer du poumon moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de tenter d'avoir un diagnostic
efficace parce que je pense encore une
fois que politiquement oui il se pose
des questions très grave très lourde que
ce soit d'ailleurs pour le service
public comme pour tous les privés sur le
terrain de l'information et des shs de
ce point de vue là nous lance un défi
considérable qui est celui oui de la
qualité de l'information je peux te dire
que dans les rédactions tout le monde en
est conscient et que ça si tu veux ça ça
ça exige savent eux il n'y a pas une
bande de types qui sont là prêts pour
dieu sait quel petit salaire ou grands
salaires at a passé le plat fourbi par
mon ami militaire ou celui de
l'ignorance de ce qui se passe
non parce que toutes ces générations
à commencer par les jeunes qui eux aussi
sont sur le numérique internet et autres
comment dire et qui travaille à la télé
savent que il faut aller au delà quoi il
faut se remuer et ils sont exigeants
eric filiol jamais de fumée sans feu
disons que moi je rejoins en grande
partie ce qu'hervé a dit il ya des
journalistes qui est de grande qualité
le problème c'est qu'il faut avoir une
vision beaucoup plus large les
journalistes ne vont plus n'évolue plus
dans un monde sol il faut il a parlé d'
agence de production il ya aussi des
agences de com et le principe de l'info
apps et d'allumer des feux des
contre-feux c'est à dire en gros au
moment où une information pertinente
sort elle et on s'arrange pour qu'elles
soient noyés moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est pas souvent la formation c'est la
corrélation de la servante d'information
présenté au même moment donc le but
effectivement moi je suis convaincu il
ya des journalistes comme élise lucet
que j'admire énormément c'est amusant de
voir comment elle est traitée elle est
traitée notamment par la servante de
communicants que je distingue les des
journalistes en fait ce système de feux
de contre-feux permet effectivement de
noyer le poisson et d'atténuer un sort
donc de très bonnes de très bons
articles travaux de réflexion mais le
problème c'est qu'effectivement
les journées ne sont pas seuls ils sont
main dans un contexte économique est
extrêmement contraint et le pouvoir de
l'argent les moyens c'est aussi aller
sur le terrain et tout ça coûte cher
maintenant
voilà c'est je pense un livre de flore
vasseur je crois que c'est à ce seul
malfaiteur le dernier le dernier
chapitre en bande organisée au regard
des erreurs
bon c'est sous couvert la romance est
pour moi une très bonne enquête qui dit
pas son nom le dernier chapitre illustre
parfaitement ce qui est en train de se
passer au niveau du journalisme versus
la communication et ce système de feux
et de contre-feu elle explique
parfaitement c'est ça il ya des
journalistes qui font très bien leur
travail qui sont particulièrement gênant
et je reviens élise lucet mois encore
une fois il perd ce que j'admire
particulièrement on voit très bien
comment elle est malmenée et par le
pouvoir politique par une certaine
partie de ses confrères j'ai discuté
avec certains de ses collègues il sait
pas facile tous les jours pour elle mais
bon voilà il ya encore des gens
courageux le problème c'est que le
courage se paye souvent cash et donc de
moins en moins seront tentés de suivre
cette voie mais denis robert a payé très
cher pierre connaissent à josé couderc
je t'aimerai si tu veux je suis toujours
un peu à la marge le procès fait aux
journalistes le procès le plus aisé à
dresser parce que tout le monde a accès
aux médias et tout le monde se dit oui
mais en fait ils racontent ci raconte ça
moi je fais plusieurs mains d'abord
qu'un événement puisse être une double
lecture
c'est quelque chose auquel nous ne
sommes pas habitués je te prends un
exemple quand les soviétiques se retire
d'afghanistan
en occident tout le monde il est le
communisme a reculé et ses voiliers
finalement notre politique a été payante
et c'est le même moment d'un communiqué
de ben laden dix ans voyez une armée de
militants de arabe musulman est capable
de gagner sur la plus traditionnelle la
plus conventionnelle des armes et la
puissance des armes conventionnelles de
votre époque mais qui va lire le
communiqué de ben laden à l'époque
personne parce que encore une fois c'est
la focale intellectuelle sur laquelle on
met hors dieu sait que l'homme qui était
promis au plus bel avenir c'était plutôt
ben laden que le ministre que le
président de l'époque je peux citer le
père bush ou pas et donc ça cette espèce
de dualité de la réalité c'est celui
qu'on est en train de vivre sur des
champs est en train de construire sur
des chemins discours de la diabolisation
du mal absolu du fait qu'il faut
extirper cette cette entité malfaisante
et c'est quoi ce truc c'est de rendre un
avis sur dit donc tu vois bien comment
le regard perverti la chose moi y'a une
chose aussi que la télévision nous a
fait naître et qui me paraît beaucoup
plus extraordinaire c'est le
présentateur de journal c'est à dire
celui qui n'est pas le journalisme est
celui qui présente les meilleurs jeunes
les reportages faits par les autres cela
devient un penseur de la société
contemporaine c'est à dire celui qui
fait plus de terrain et celui qui
devient le penseur de l'information je
veux pas de citer des exemples enfin ça
m'a toujours beaucoup choqué et la
dernière chose c'est qu'encore une fois
il n'ya pas que les journalistes qui
font de l'information il ya tous les
autres alors il ya évidemment les boîtes
de com qui interviennent de plus en plus
dans la gestion de tus et l'invention
concomitante de la publicité de la
propagande c'est quand même un épisode
historique qui est intéressante parce
que la publicité c'est rien de plus que
de la propagande commerciale et la
propagande ça n'est rien de plus que de
la publicité politique c'est quand même
ça la méthode d'ailleurs je recommande
un très bon livre et tu as aujourd'hui
des gens comme des intellectuels
médiatiques qui vont faire l'opinion
parce que leur capacité à agir sur
l'opinion en faisant un grand article
pour se placer au niveau des principes
pour dire que l'on ne devrait jamais
laisser faire il faut absolument
exterminer ces vermines etc
comme bhv belge faillie bhl pendant
qu'on fonctionne mais on peut contrôler
la même chose si on trouve tout chez bhl
toute façon et donc on a effectivement
des gens qui sont capables d'agir sur le
politique pour prendre une décision qui
ne fait jamais l'objet d'une d'un débat
qui fait jamais l'objet d'un débat
parlementaire et donc ces gens là aussi
sont des gens qu'il faut
fondamentalement
dénoncer et ça que ça je même vu un type
qui un jour a expliqué un pro de
l'afghanistan que il fallait faire un
grand plan marshall pour l'afghanistan
s'il fallait développer l'industrie un
deuxième temps le type il n'avait jamais
mis les pieds en afghanistan quand on
connaît l'afghanistan c'est la dernière
idée d'où il vient mais il était à paris
il écrivait dans un grand quotidien du
matin et donc voilà ce type était là en
train de dire peut-être qu'il aurait
débloqué du fric en plus donc on fait
attention à l'opinion publique n'est pas
faite que par les journalistes elle est
faite par un certain nombre d'acteurs
dans lesquels tu vas avoir l'historien
qui va expliquer que depuis longtemps la
france est le pays des droits de l'homme
alors que la dea constitution américaine
de 1776 tu vas avoir un le géographe qui
va expliquer que la france ait
d'ensemble des terres habitées et que
donc par là même c'est le pays de
l'harmonie tu veux avoir les juristes
qui vont expliquer que le droit
international le droit de l'homme en 48
ont été écrits par un français rené
cassin alors qu'on était la deuxième
puissance coloniale de la planète
donc tu vois c'est tout ça c'est
important et ça il faut le prendre en
compte hervé est ce que tu t'es poser la
question sur pourquoi les gens avaient
ciblé en priorité les journalistes par
rapport à cette déliquescence sociétale
parce qu'ils le font encore une fois
depuis très longtemps parce que vous
êtes les plus proches d'eux et que vous
êtes le quatrième pouvoir oui c'est ça
oui bien sûr parce que ceux qui prennent
le pire de rien pouvoir sas voilà déjà
on est dans
moi je ne sais pas si le quatrième le
cinquième on est
on incarne une capacité stupéfiante dans
une société qui consiste à être préposé
au discours de vérité tout ce qu'ils
vont dire la vérité
et donc
historiquement dans l'antiquité ça c'est
parfois passer assez mal pour les mecs
qui disait la vérité ce soit des
philosophes ou des coureurs de marathon
mais au delà de la plaisanterie
le le le la fonction de dire la vérité
est une fonction de récits de narration
qui n'a qu'une valeur relative par
rapport à l'engagement et l'implication
personnelle des gens par exemple on a
souvent dit que c'étaient les
journalistes qui faisaient des bulletins
de vote mais heureusement que ça ne se
passe pas comme ça sinon les français et
le monde entier serait une population de
vous
regardant la télé parce que qu'est-ce
que je peux t'arrêter oui c'est qu'on a
mis en lumière quand même le
le fait que plus un homme politique qui
représentait à la télé plus sa cote de
popularité augmente quand même est-ce
que tu as entendu est-ce que tu as
entendu les dernières déclarations de de
notre ami vendéen quand il s'appelle de
villiers est ce que tu as suivi ce qui
est raconté par rapport au fait qu'il
avait un de ses amis qui sponsorisait sa
campagne qui dit bon il faut acheter du
tf1 comme s'en passera plus sur tf1
construisent dans les instituts de son
ami qu'est ce t'en penses je pense que
c'est une et une grossièreté majeur
il ya eu un président de la république
qui adorait passer à la télé qui a
d'ailleurs en terme de com innover
des repas avec les éboueurs des ide goût
des chiffres de ce matin
qui est dépassé très fortement à la télé
et qui pour le coup l'avait mise ici est
là en coupe réglée
il n'a pas été réélu ce garçon ça n'est
pas aussi simple la propagande le
fonctionnement de la propagande dans son
ne sont comment dire son efficacité est
heureusement choses un peu plus complexe
que diffusion d'un message est un
réflexe animal de la personne
je voudrais juste dire une chose il ya
un truc qui est quand même assez rigolo
pour moi c'est que les journalistes sont
mis en accusation et c'est bien
d'ailleurs parce que comme le disait
l'homme ex dgse ricci le je sais mais je
on s'amuse
c'est que
du coup tu m'as fait perdre ma pensée
c'est que le journalisme
est absolument triomphant
en ce sens que tu aujourd'hui
tu va repartir pourquoi parce que tout
le monde aujourd'hui à capacité à
produire sa vérité et ça je trouve non
c'est pas un problème c'est de ganges
raghu rai émergence de groof et
nomination est impossible tu as raison
mais c'est ça aussi le fourmillement de
la démocratie il faut savoir l'accepter
quand même c'est pas à moi de te le dire
donc les formes utili utiliser
le la brièveté
pardon mais sont des techniques qui ont
été mises en place dans un art de faire
hautement respectable qui est un vrai
métier qui s'appelle le journalisme et
je prétends qu'aujourd'hui le
journalisme est effectivement triomphant
et j'ose espérer que il le sera il sera
plus satisfaisant pour la démocratie
aujourd'hui qu'il ne le fut mais c'est
cette capacité d'information et encore
une fois comment dire ordonné comme tu
sais par exemple je me souviens qu'un
sociologue avait travaillé sur la
conversation et de voir à quel point de
journalisme avait changé les modalités
de la conversation les avait rendues
plus brèves avait obligé les gens à
aller plus vite à l'essentiel parce que
voilà il ya il ya toute cette force là
d'un art de fer permanent qu'on voit à
la télévision je crois moi davantage à
une formation à une implication sur la
vie des gens de cet ordre là que la
simple fabrication d'une opinion et d'un
bulletin de vote c'est beaucoup plus
insidieux beaucoup plus profond c'est
plus complexe et c'est pour ça que ça
vaut le coup qu'on s'y penche davantage
en termes d'intelligence de ce qui se
passe que en termes de grande baffe dans
la gueule que je vais me prendre n'y a
pas de souci la supprimer ou moins
parce que j'ai toujours été candidat ça
moi je viens c'est pour parler avec les
personnes et donc pour essayer d'avoir
cet échange je suis pas en train de
plaider une sorte de pseudo virginie et
on est tous d'en faire et c'est génial
non c'est très compliqué mais ce que je
souhaite c'est simplement dans le
respect que moi je dois aux gens que au
retour respecte ma complexité parce que
j'en ai une et que ça n'est pas si
simple eric filiol on a vu émerger un
pouvoir un pouvoir à coeur on a été
obligé de sortir du bois qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que tu peux nous en dire
d'abord il a déjà il est depuis très
longtemps je faut quand même expliqué qu
internet est né avec les hackers d'abord
on pense souvent que les hackers sont
des gens qui attaquent il faut quand
même pas oublier qu ils ce sont des gens
qui ont créé les premiers protocoles
agir même le gouvernement américain même
s'il veut pas le reconnaître quand même
sous traiter le une bonne partie de la
création d'internet à ce qu'on appelait
autrefois des universitaires mais les
universitaires d'autrefois étaient plus
proches des hackers que les
universitaires d'aujourd'hui ouais
je reviens quand même à ce que disait
hervé le problème c'est que on est on a
perdu la culture de la prise de risque
et le problème c'est que dans le
journaliste qui fait son travail
c'est un peu comme les bons et les
mauvais chasseurs savent pour reprendre
et le problème c'est qu'on confond
souvent le message de le messager or en
france prend prendre du risque et je
parlais des fonctionnaires c'était
devenu totalement étranger à notre
culture donc dès qu'il y en a un qui
essaye de faire les choses correctement
de faire des choses et donc de prendre
des risques il se fait allumer
méchamment mais les hackers quelque part
ou un peu cette position quand ils
arrivent ils disent ah bah ça et moi je
vais vous montrer que tel industriel qui
est sponsorisé par l'état il a fait un
truc et tient pas la route parce que on
est rentré dedans par différentes
manières et engrossé du travail
d'amateur il est clair que le message a
du mal à passer et qu'il est plutôt vu
comme liquette est le gré de pirates
parce que ça arrange les gens alors
qu'en réalité c'est un lanceur de la
guerre technologique et qui l'a mis là
il a fait oeuvre utile donc dans le
domaine spécifique parce que l'essentiel
des hackers à son travail plutôt dans le
domaine technique même si on voit
émerger des hackers plus humain plc yvon
ac essayer de comprendre comment se font
les lois ou autre donc cette démarche
intellectuelle un peu intéressante mais
ils sont pas bien vus en particulier en
français c'est assez paradoxal parce
qu'en france on a un des meilleurs
communauté à coeur au monde et aux
concepts sont là mais non seulement la
méprise
on se coupe d'elle complètement mais ils
sont vu effectivement chaque fois que
comme des du poil à gratter et voir dans
de dangereux activistes terroristes
simpliste des choses je crois que bien
aspect que les médias dans laquelle les
médias ont largement pesé parce que leur
dynamique économique imposé le certain
nombre de choix bon grosso modo si on
regarde le bouquin monde rebelles qui
est la seule référence
globale de l'ensemble des crises
insurrection guerre etc la surface de la
planète grosso modo y en a 400 à 450 ça
dépend des années mais comment se fait
le choix puisque justement tu poser la
question au départ d une dépêche de l
afp l afp est un formidable que les
capteurs d'information bien supérieur à
ce qui est notre réseau diplomatique
parce que encore une fois c'est un
travail de journaliste les gens
n'hésitent pas à les voir celui qui
pense mal alors qu'un ambassadeur se
fait sanctionner si justement il va voir
le type qui pensent mal et donc ça c'est
très important comprendre et donc
comment se fait ce choix question que tu
poses et au départ après tu as une
contrainte diplomatique c'est à dire tu
as là la fois la dynamique des acteurs
et puis tu as la dynamique du système
médiatique les acteurs bas il faut
d'abord qu'ils ont un certain nombre de
caractéristiques pour se faire connaître
il faut qu'ils correspondent à des
critères médiatique faut qu'ils aient un
leader charismatique genre le dalaï lama
par exemple très vivant sur terre tu es
dans ton fait citoyen d'honneur de la
ville de paris capitale la validité ce
qui est une performance il faut
effectivement des combattants qui se
reconnaissent donc si tu as des bonzes
avec des trucs doré orange safran c'est
quand même mieux que si tu as des
combattants palestiniens en tenue
camouflée en fait tu vois il ya un
certain nombre de critères ça c'est 3 et
deuxième chose devant l'as tu entres
dans la médiatisation du conflit il faut
des images pas d'image pas de crise donc
ça il faut se rendre compte comment veux
tu faire un journal dans une chaîne
d'info en continu pour parler d'une
crise qui va se passer quelque part dans
le nord du mexique mais août à rien
troisième chose il ya un timing de la
venue des médias c'est à dire tu sais
pas mais un journal télévisé tu peux
parler d'eux crise internationale pas
plus tu vas pas de traiter 25 crise le
message se dilue et dernière chose il ya
le timing médiatique du reste du monde
tu as n'ont jamais une crise pendant les
jeux olympiques ou la coupe du monde de
football c'est pas la peine les médias
sont saturés avec ça et donc tous ces
critères là sont des filtres qui sont
pas volontaires qui sont des filtres
mécanique et qui font que effectivement
alors prenons le cas de l'arabie
saoudite que j'adore par dessus tout un
journaliste qui vont en arabie saoudite
d'abord effectivement il faut qu'il
accepte d'en accepte dans les sphères
décisionnelles s'est pas seulement voir
les frasques des princes saoudiens c'est
voir comment fonctionnent les oulémas
c'est ce qu'ils disent la terre est
plate elle tourne pas sur elle même
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est que si on
avions partaient dryades et que la terre
tournait sur l'allemagne pourrait jamais
arriver à pékin je te cite une base qui
était le grand tous les membres
ces gens là qu'il faut rencontrer parce
que c'est le seul qui sont là c'est la
société saoudienne profonde ensuite un
universitaire si le mec s'amuse à
raconter ce que c'est vraiment l'arabie
saoudite mais il perd son père un
peuplier et c'est un homme politique qui
s'amusent à critiquer l'arabie saoudite
je te laisse je te laisse supposer
comment il va être rappelé à l'ordre par
ses petits camarades parce que premiers
clients français en matière d'armement
depuis 20 ans moyenne lissée de très
loin et en plus on sait que c'est un
pays qui achètent des armes pour pas les
utiliser ça paye que jamais fait la
guerre israël alors que la frontière est
à une quarantaine de kilomètres donc ça
va pourquoi va-t-on se poser des
problèmes puis je pensais que il achète
pas des armes ils achètent des
anxiolytiques qu'ils achètent des
garanties de sécurité
donc tu vois c'est problématique il faut
les vivre de l'intérieur lodetti people
tu acheté des frégates ils en ont planté
une sur des rochers la fois ils ont
voulu les présenter au prince au prince
ministre de la défense le mec il ya dix
ans reflète les mois passent et le type
i like advienne crack qui s'est planté
et on a fait un magnifique contrat qui
savaient le contrat mouettes tue c'est
bon pour réparer les frégates que le
type est planté et donc on est dans
cette logique là c'est à dire jusqu'à ce
que vraiment le débat saoudiens
apparaissaient encore une fois par des
mécanismes qui sont un mélange de
médiatisation un mélange d'alert
militaire un mélange d'alert de crise
etc les dossiers n'apparaissent pas et
donc encore une fois il faut le prendre
dans sa totalité c'est quand même
extraordinaire qu'on arrive à le
revendre de laboratoire p4 comme un
autre alors ça c'est magnifique ça c'est
prodigieux parce que encore une fois il
faut être dans l'arabie saoudite le ch
celui qui est le dernier qui a vu un
saoudien travailler s'il n'est pas là à
laboratoire p4 pour nos auditeurs qui
explique un peu alors un laboratoire p4
laboratoire extrêmement sensible qui
permet de faire de travailler sur des
souches biologique extrêmement
dangereuses dont il ya des conditions
d'isolement de pratiques etc de filtrage
précédent mais qui évidemment peuvent
servir à mettre en place des armes de
destruction massive qui peuvent à
blizzard théologie biologique et de
cette robe est donc ce sont des critères
extrêmement strictes si tu veux de
fonctionnement d'un laboratoire de cette
nature c'est toute la difficulté du
débat sur les armes bactériologiques
parce que les armes bactériologiques le
meilleur endroit pour faire des armes
bactériologiques cet hôpital donc
évidemment comment on va contrôler tous
les hôpitaux de la planète en disant
attention là y'a un laboratoire qui
travaille sur la souche de la variole la
plus dangereuse le meilleur exemple
c'est le sait la crise de l'anthrax
après le 11 septembre tout le monde l'a
oublié la crise de l'anthrax presse tu
te souviens de cette crise c'est à dire
les banques ont reçu des enveloppes il y
avait des petits dés de la petite poudre
blanche et ses abords alors juste un
détail par rapport aux souches dans
tracks je connais très bien bob kane qui
est un ami qui a vu le film on track
soir ou marchands d'anthrax essaye de
revenir un petit peu sur la souche dans
tracks qui a été envoyé un petit peu aux
etats-unis c'était une souche commandes
à l'autoriser d'abord il faut bien se
rendre compte que on était dans les
effets du 11 septembre c'est à dire que
la télévision les médias américains est
complètement focalisé sur les victimes
intrigues pourquoi je vous aime pas etc
etc sur ce se diffuse par la poste un
certain nombre d' enveloppe contenant
des bastides et des ports d'anthrax
militarisée parce que c'est pendant
notre action s'est rendu compte que le
travail la militarisation de la porte
entre axe consiste à essayer de la
rendre la plus fine possible de façon à
ce qu'elles pénètrent le plus
profondément possible dans l'organisme
ce qui prouve qu'il ya des gens quand
même pour qui l'éthique morale de là
alors on peut expliquer que c'est pour
se prémunir contre ce genre de risque
c'est ça aussi la dualité du comment
dire de l'esprit mhz ainsi on fait du
mal c'est pour le grand le plus grand
bien de l'humanité les souris dont les
souches journée dans la branche
militaire et donc on a su qu'ils
sortaient d'un laboratoire militaire ce
qui en même temps prouvé qu'en dépit de
la conversion chimique les américains
continuent à entretenir de laboratoires
de fabrication d'armes bactériologiques
qu'ils expliqué par le fait qu' il
fallait se prémunir contre ces maladies
dont il fallait continuer à travailler
et donc une des raisons qui fait que par
exemple les conventions sur les armes
bactériologiques ne marche pas c'est que
à la suite des états unis tout le monde
explique qu'on doit protéger un secret
industriel
c'est à dire qu'on glisse du sécuritaire
particulièrement dangereux dont on va
accuser l'autre de le pratiquer pour te
dire mais moi je suis obligé de me
prévenir donc je fais la même chose
alors on n'est pas ça sur des supports
militaire mais en tout état de cause la
crise de l'anthrax est largement et
disparut de la scène médiatique elle est
passée sous les radars parce que toute
la problématique des néoconservateurs et
est aujourd'hui il faut se venger on
nous a déclaré la guerre il faut faire
la guerre et donc c est à ce moment
c'est silence dans les rangs tu vois le
truc est donc cette articulation entre
l'actualité brûlante le rôle des médias
le travail de fond et les vérités
historiques
je te rappelle que le plus gros le
premier correspondant de guerre c'est
hérodote qui part avec alexandre
pendant les guerres de conquêtes
d'alexandre il va présenter alexandre
comme le représentant de la démocratie
grecque alors qu'il a soumis toutes les
cités grecques et qui va présenter
l'empiré perse comme la dictature alors
qu'en fait la composante que tu regardes
la décomposition de l'armée perse était
une armée respectueuse de toutes les
minorités de lempire de l'époque mais
comme ces hérodote qui écrit l'histoire
c'est fini les rôles sont posés on à la
démocratie grecque l'époque il a un mec
qui valent le critiquer fortement que
s'appelle thucydide ouais c'est vrai qui
lui a fait des guerres et autres qui
veut pas que ça recommence vous voyez ça
date de longtemps et qui dit lui vérifie
pas ses infos moi je vais les vérifier
et donc fait le très rock lui fait un
premier travail fondateur qui dit faut
aller sur place pour savoir ce qui se
passe et il fait tout le tour de la
méditerranée
il écrit un gros machin qui s'appelle l'
enquête que j'habite à lire parce que ça
se lit comme un roman policier par
exemple tu es en egypte tu viens d'avoir
à mort dans ta famille et tu reçois la
visite des mecs pour embaumer ton parent
l'état tout le discours de est-ce qu'on
embaume la tête et où et combien ça va
me coûter tout autrement dit quand tu
vas hulu voir les momies que tu as lu ça
tu le vois déjà autrement et thucydide
lui après il dit ok oui faut aller sur
le terrain mais faut vérifier recouper
et donc il il a introduit la notion des
sources et de la multiplicité des
sources
je vais quand je t'entends je pense aux
charniers de timisoara donc sa mèche
jamais timisoara mais tu as parfaitement
raison je l' ai vécu en direct
durant non guillaume durand était sur
une autre chaîne et moi j'étais hélas ou
tant mieux pour moi en reja sur le
service public bonjour et donc on se les
prix comme ça et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pardon mais il y avait déjà des
dépêches des dépêches réécrite à paris
parce qu'on a fait l'histoire de
timisoara on a essayé de comprendre d'où
venait votre podium oui bien sûr mais
c'est paris qui avait fait confiance à
une agence yougoslave à l'époque
s'appelle tam ue et qui avaient réécrit
en fonction de ce que nos amis à
l'époque du kgb et autres avaient bien
fermenté et le truc a fonctionné mais
peu de temps car la vérité d'une
escroquerie ne durent que le temps la
vérité de cette escroquerie et on doit
aussi à la fois aux historiens et à tous
les confrères journalistes d'avoir fait
le travail d'autocritique les gens de là
espérons écrit là-dessus et pour faire
en sorte que ça ne redémarre pas mais
peut-être que demain il y aura un autre
timisoara c'est possible mais après le
contrepoison doit venir c'est ça la
démocratie
et puis je vais insister sur un aspect
qui est quand même le rôle du spectateur
c'est à dire qu'il a lui même à ma
grande culture l absolu n'est absolu
d'amande le pays de l'harmoniciste
devraine parce que pour l'instant aux
formes plus d'écho sommet toc des
citoyens à l'école oui je peux pas
t'empêcher de penser que de toute façon
on a tous un background culturel et que
ses bagages au scanner celui qui va
recevoir le message si tu veux le cette
fois de la façon dont on va formaté
l'information parce qu'il faut aussi que
le spectateur la comprennent est un
travail essentiel et donc le background
culturel moyen des exemples qui me
frappe toujours c'est la production
hollywoodienne
puisque le western est quand même un
style cinématographique dans lequel
c'est le génocide heures le cowboy qui
est le héros et c'est la valaisanne ya
des barbares qui font massacrer et on a
tous adhéré à ce discours ça veut dire
qu'avec une certaine forme tu as aussi
des mécanismes de production du filtre
intellectuelle l'individu qui est
extrêmement important je prends un
exemple récent coup recours à un cours
non une raison très simple si american
saveur locale peur c'est un massacre ont
fait un héros d'un type qui tire un
kilomètre et demi sur ses victimes
puisque quand même pas vraiment le
combattant du front et en plus on ne le
présente comme le type qui revient de
trois quatre fois sur le front et ses
puits vont ressembler qui s'emmerdent
chez lui quoi bon la partie la plus
intéressante c'est quand même quand il
est assassiné par un grillage qui a été
traumatisé par la guerre mais ça ça
n'est pas traitée par clint eastwood
c'est pas intéressant en même temps tu
as sur internet film fait partie viper
irakien qui s'appelle juba et donkey et
montre les prises de vue qu'il a fait
quand ils tuent des soldats américains
et tu te dis mais lequel des deux est un
film de propagande mais 2 où il y en a
qui ne l'est pas ou dans ce cas là il
faut que dire pourquoi ou alors il faut
considérer que les deux ont le même
mécanisme problème et c'est ça qui
forment l'opinion donc le journaliste
qui va revenir en iran 10 en irak ont
fait un sale boulot à venir on attendait
monsieur nous sommes l'état de la démo
que nous sommes la démocratie ne sont le
droit eric filiol le background culturel
du spectateur
il est important mais moi je crains que
alimenté par là
la seule culture américaine ils
disparaissent enfin on a un recul quand
même de la culture générale de ce
l'instant aux juges à à la lumière d'une
de la génération actuelle qui a encore
qui a été formé par un système éducatif
qui était quand même beau mais quand je
dis que notre système éducatif formel en
plus des consommateurs plutôt que des
citoyens ça veut dire que d'ici 10 ans
on aura des populations totalement
inculte dans bien des domaines le
rouleau compresseur
américain avec les séries qui polluent
l'esprit de nos jeunes
quand on supprime les épreuves de
culture générale entrées de grandes
écoles pendant pas pour ne pas les citer
ça concourt pas à maintenir un niveau 1
niveau disons de deux préoccupations de
du téléspectateur ou du lecteur à un
niveau suffisant donc en gros si on fait
des vhu général de gaulle disait des
volets veaux sont justes connectés
maintenant avec internet quand on voit
avec quelle frénésie les gens se
précipitent pour l'acheter un apple ou
autres qui paient une fortune voilà
venir on a on allait mener vous
connecter j'ai juste un mot sur ce que
tu viens de dire moi j'étais aux états
unis au mois d'août les fusions aux
états unis tu as des drapeaux américains
partout sur les bagnoles sur le barbecue
pour les toits des maisons et donc je me
suis dit mais pour comment peut-on être
si fier d'appartenir à une nation qui a
et esclavagiste génocide et à l'égard
des indiens ségrégationniste jusqu'aux
années 60 est encore raciste aujourd'hui
comme le montre un certain de prise de
vue donc à la fin j'ai posé la question
parce que je dans une librairie je
voulais voir comment était fait les
manuels d'enseignement de l'histoire le
type m'a dit no ya pas de manuels
d'enseignement de l'histoire vous avez
une série de biographies de héros
américain alors une année ont fait
l'histoire de l'état laquelle on dans
lequel on est l'alabama l'iowa ce que tu
veux ensuite on fait une année
d'histoire des états unis parfaitement
fini ce temps de l'histoire du monde et
cette espèce de décérébration est
extraordinaire à vivre parce
qu'effectivement les types qui y entrent
dans ce monde ont l'impression d'un prêt
comme l'éthique yvon adf ils sont dans
la société parfaite et alors je pose la
question un type il me dit mais nous le
passé ne nous intéressent pas c'est
l'avenir qui nous intéresse
j'étais les bras ballants savais pas
quoi dire alors je vais vous poser une
question à tous les trois concernant le
ce qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment l'état d'urgence l'état d'urgence
hervé
qu'est ce t'en penses l'état d'urgence
si ça se prolonge un peu trop s'il ya un
transfert de la politique sécuritaire
américaine sur la l'europe et la france
en particulier c'est à dire un patriote
ac bien serré un état d'urgence qui
devient commun le mda tu ne diras si tu
connais le mda à national defence
autorisation actes
si on commence à voir des camps
d'internement où de rétention com aux
etats-unis le hr je pourrais être le
retrouver et qu'est ce t'en penses je
pense que le warning c'est déjà allumé
au moment de la loi sur le renseignement
et que on a commencé très fortement à
s'agiter
c'est à dire à faire marcher notre
petite curiosité la mise en question de
la mise en débat et que quelque part ça
quand même été assez opératoire sur une
ou deux choses il ya eu des reculs qui
font que par exemple
l'investigation journalistique est
encore possible alors qu'on aurait voulu
la limite et je parle surtout du secret
industriel et de la manière dont on
voulait l'utiliser pour comment dire
stopper toute curiosité qualifié de
malsaine
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
évidemment état d'urgence il ya urgence
à rester plus que vigilants et en
question permanente en
travail de 2 comment dire
d'interrogation au plus haut point dans
toutes les éditions et par exemple je
sais que sur le numérique chez nomura
france tv info on a déjà essayé de
devoir tout ce qui sortait tout ce qui
était abusif et donc on récolte tout ça
on fait ce travail donc que j'aime pas
me prendre pour un soldat du genre les
sentinelles de la démocratie tout ça
c'est vraiment du
ces du verbiage voilà tu fais un
signe assez explicite mais on ne voit
pas je suis assez d'accord là dessus en
revanche c'est de notre fonction de
notre rôle que de le faire ça ça fait
aussi partie du défi lancé par la
situation par la question terroriste
comment une démocratie répond-t-elle à
l'action terroriste et comment
l'information se définit-elle par
rapport à ça sur le chapitre crucial des
libertés
je suis descendu en plateau parce que on
m'a demandé ça le lendemain matin du
bataclan et de ce qui s'était passé à
saint denis et j'ai commencé à parler
effectivement de cette affaire de
restriction de liberté parce qu'ils
médiatement on n'est pas né de la
dernière pluie on sait qu'il y aura ça
et donc on sait que à tout moment il
faut
continuer à mettre en question et faire
en sorte que des pentes comme ça qui
pourraient s'offrir à tous les pouvoirs
qu'ils soient de droite de gauche et
j'espère pas d'autres
feront que on n'ira pas aux ben quoi y
figurent l'état d'urgence moi je pense
que c'est une stupidité d'abord c'est
méconnaître
comment de ces gens là fonctionne sans
que j'ai bloqué en trail sur certaines
affaires on voit qu'ils savent de mieux
en mieux passer sous le radar donc c'est
pas une loi extrêmement liberticide qui
va permettre de détecter des
informations je rappelle quand même que
les renseignements les plus pertinents
nous étonner fournis par le maroc membre
du conseil de sécurité l'onu avec la
bombe atomique on est quand même à la
ramasse en termes de renseignements moi
je pense que si il ya une urgence assez
clair aux personnes peut le nier mais je
préférerais une réaction de type
churchill qui disait bas les gars on va
tous se retrousser et je vous promet du
sang et des larmes plutôt qu'une vision
plutôt de type erich honecker rdr parce
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est plutôt une
approche de type stasi on peut critiquer
les états unis avec leur patriot act et
août mais il ya un certain nombre de
contre pouvoir qui fonctionne très bien
et notamment de la société civile on
peut citer l'electronic frontier
foundation
l'aclu ou autre donc c'est pas fait mais
j'aimerais qu'on ait ce genre de
contre-pouvoir on ne l'a pas et je
crains que le l'état d'urgence soit un
alibi
on prenne justement des éléments
factuels pour mettre en place quelque
chose qui ne dit pas son nom la
surveillance de la société fonds comme
sac la loi sur l'enseignement
révélé à la dans l'émotion des attentats
de janvier était en préparation quand
même depuis trois ans il faut faut quand
même avoir cette vision est historique
moi je suis assez inquiet d'abord je
pense que ça ne réglera rien là encore
on à la jirs est entre guillemets
beaucoup de respect pour les familles
qui ont été touchés on a eu affaire à
une bande d'amateurs
demain quand ils vont apprendre de leurs
erreurs et qu'ils vont s'en tirer un peu
plus en mode bédouins un mode militaire
on ne verra rien c'est donc on pour
amasser des gens derrière des
ordinateurs
c'est une illusion totale
par contre
permettre une surveillance globale de
comment s'appelle de la population ça
c'est intéressant mais c'est pas il se
trouve que la france n'avait plus de
zèle que d'autres pays c'est une
tendance générale d'un certain nombre de
pays et ça on a encore la vision
américaine faut comprendre que nos
décideurs sont paniqués par le
changement de la société ils sont passés
d'une société pompidolienne où on avait
des élites qui parlait à la basse
laquelle prenaient ça comme d une vérité
révélée un monde horizontale
collaboratif les gens peuvent vérifier
l'information une information sur
internet elle existe dix ans après on
peut la croiser serre que le citoyen
pour peu qu'ils veuillent être
intelligent a les moyens de le rester et
de développer son intelligence
collective et ça ça fait peur à nos
dirigeants parce que bon sang ça veut
dire qu'ils ne sont plus cette élite
révélé et qu'en gros insulte le peuple
se met à réfléchir à penser en plus avec
intelligent alors qu'on passe notre
temps à les prendre pour des cons donc
au bout d'un vent et il faut pas
s'étonner c'est pas des veaux le
problème c'est que le système vous
voudrez les maintenir cet état de
consommateurs et donc on peut faire
confiance un peu aux gens quand vous lui
il ya moi je crois en la france a
traversé
à travers ces décrivent très grave et
allen capacité de résilience on est
quand même un tournant où je pense qu'on
est en train d'être anesthésié data ou
par ce modèle américain moi que je au
nous parce qu'il est en train de
lobotomiser nos jeunes la limite nous on
fait partie des vieux sûr qu'on a encore
des références d'avant cette période je
suis plus inquiet pour les jeunes qui de
qui sont effectivement dans une qui
subissent une lobotomie 21 ans qu'est ce
que c'est les américains l'ont compris
ils ont dit les vieux c'est pas la peine
sont ils sont résistants et on n'en fera
rien qui sont indécrottables travaillons
sur la génération actuelle les jeunes
dans 25 ans faut quand même pas oublier
que beaucoup de nos élites
gouvernementales actuellement en poste
mais du gouvernement précédent ont été
formés par exemple dans la dalle dans le
mouvement des young americans leader on
peut citer tous nos hommes politiques et
sortir la date de promo ça qu'ils ont
été formés à la pensée américaine
je suis désolée la france n'est pas
condamnée à choisir entre l'ancien bloc
ou un autre elle peut être un bloc en
elle-même pierre connaissant l'état
d'urgence et les élites américaines mind
non moi je suis moi même je suis moins
critique que vous d'abord parce que j'ai
toujours été amusés par le débat sur la
défense des libertés publiques à je
lisais récemment un article dans le
monde où il y avait un avocat qui
explique les mesures pris contre les
hooligans dans les stades de football
était attentatoire aux libertés donc si
tu veux la profileuse la thématique
venir le défenseur des droits de l'homme
est devenu une profession à temps plein
tu as des gens quitter internet surtout
sur la loi sur le renseignement attendu
mais des conneries mais un sondage lh2
bêtises les types pensé qu'on allait
tous écouté la totalité de la population
ce que tu sais ce que c'est le dpi à
tintin finir quand appris métro comme
moi que tu entends les conversations que
les gens se tiennent dans le métro tu te
dis si les services de renseignement ils
ont autre chose à [__] ils ont rien
d'autre à [__] que d'écouter ça c'est
combien mesurait combien ça pourrait
même annoncer plus un mec avec des
écouteurs comme dans la vie des autres
l'informateur tu sais le sérum ce fut
elle qui disait ça dans une
truc du congrès le renseignement c'est
ce que tu sais que tu sais ce que tu
sais que tu sais pas ce que tu sais pas
que tu sais ce que tu sais pas tu sais
pas alors une fois que tu as fait bilan
critique tu te dis oui les mecs ils
avaient une fiche s so what une fois que
tu dit d'avis une fiche est ce la
question c'est qu'est ce que tu penses
qu'il risque de faire par rapport à la
connexion que tu sais que ce type avec
telles et telles étaient les tables
étals mais ça si tu veux c'est parce
qu'on vit tous dans le mirage du film
d'espionnage on pense que jazz monde à
lui tout seul connecter avec story
sylvester stallone et et schwarzenegger
ils vont sauver la planète tous les
jours mais c'est pas comme ça le travail
il est d'une modestie artisanale pour
une fois rappelle toi que dans le cas de
coulis bachy coulibaly d'art kwasi
coulibaly le la dg acier avait un
contingent des coûte réglementée par une
commission administrative dans les cas
tu avais certainement à conseiller
d'état et de la cour des comptes à dire
des mecs qui ne connaissent rien aux
renseignements est donc à chaque fois
qu'il devait changer une écoute où on
peut éventuellement excès tendre une
écoute genre sur les femmes dès
l'arrivée 2 il fallait qu'ils fassent un
dossier administratif qui monte à la
commission que la commission donne son
avis est que ça redescende et qui
sortent du contingent une écoute quand
tu es dans un système comme celui là
encore une fois il faut un peu se
tempérer dans la critique de la loi sur
le renseignement parce que sur le
patriot act il ya des aspects scandaleux
mais qui concerne le rapport des
américains que le reste du monde les
américains eux-mêmes que je sache c'est
pas devenu une dictature depuis le
patriot act donc il faut tempérer la
chose faut être ciblés dans les
critiques pas le dire comme si c'était
tout à coup le big brother qui allait
commencer si on savait effectivement
écouter tu sais les gens pensent qu
effectivement dans le bureau ovale c'est
en particulier ceux qui courent beaucoup
d'amis à ramon pascal dormal la maison
blanche le mec il décide sur une carte
et qu il sait tout sur tout ce n'est pas
vrai c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
vérifiez voulait rebondir le problème
c'est que la loi rosheim ans il fallait
une loi message rejoint pierre là dessus
le problème ce qui gêne c'est l'absence
quasi totale de
contre-pouvoir on est dans une joie si
tu fais des contrôles administratifs
tu te retrouves avec la viscosité de
cette société n'entend pas dans
l'exemple de la cnil dans la cnil nous
avons par exemple si quelqu'un pense
avoir fait l'objet d'une recherche il y
à des magistrats et je regrette que l'on
ait reçu un renseignement les magistrats
a été totalement écartée
ces groupes juge trévidic qui est quand
même pas
quelqu'un de partir en intelligent il
est tout aussi critique le problème
c'est que ce magistrat allez voir dans
les fichiers disait monsieur non je ne
peux pas vous dire ce que j'ai vu mais
c'est conforme à l'esprit de la cnil il
suffisait de faire ce genre de choses
moi ce qui me gêne c'est la
précipitation avec laquelle on fait et
l'opacité extrême il n'y a pas eu de
débat en tout cas maintenant il y avait
urgence urgence il y avait nécessité de
faire cette fois voilà maintenant ce qui
me gêne le plus c'est que la france est
de moins en moins d'analystes prenons un
exemple le l'angleterre a restructuré
son enseignement et l à environ 1000
analystes en propre c'est d'ailleurs des
gens qui travaillent pour l'état en
france nous en avons à peine deux cents
pourquoi parce que nos services ont sous
traité certes il y à là problème la
problématique de la captation du
renseignement certains caps le
renseignement de mieux en mieux
seulement on a de moins en moins
l'analyse c'est facile de capter des
informations mais quand c'est dans une
langue qu'on comprend pas que ça
nécessite un arrière plan culturel qu'on
ne comprend plus parce qu'on a viré tous
les spécialistes alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait eh bien la france sous traitent le
traitement de ce renseignement des
sociétés privées le dernier c'était
intelligence notebook qu'est ce qui
s'est passé intelligence notebook a été
racheté par ibm merde on va quand même
pas faire traiter notre enseignement par
une société américaine non mais c'est
pas sûr qu'ils aient une chance notebook
vue sont noués tête et françaises dès le
départ qu'est ce qui se passe on va
recommencer de zéro donc 200 analystes
pour la france à peu près 1000 analyse
pour l'angleterre une capacité en propre
pour l'angleterre en france on devrait
obliger de sous traiter à des sociétés
privées et ce qui me gêne c'est que la
chose régaliennes comment cette
retraitée de plus en plus par des
entités privées
je suis fier parce que me l'analyste
c'est très bien mais tu avais
simultanément le nom de distance avec
les défenseurs de la liberté sur le
thème donnons leur le terreau est une
terre d'asile la liberté de parole pas
question de censure et j'ai assisté à
des prêches avait pas corner par des
mecs du londonistan c'était d'une haine
de racisme de l'antisémitisme absolument
intolérable et on avait des défenseurs
de la liberté mais nous notre pays c'est
alors nommé là tempère un peu sur la
thématique de la liberté les droits de
l'homme et remarques de vieux cons je
dînais 2 1 ok eric
je sais aussi que par rapport aux
analystes il en va de même pour le
journalisme et les reporters il faut des
mecs de terrain et il faut être au plus
près pour comprendre parce que le prêche
faut être là pour l'entente rien que ça
c'est déjà très important
tomtom m mais je vous avais parlé de
culture américaine vous avez parlé de
tout ça il ya il ya eu un shooting de
masse aux états unis en californie
je vais vous passez un extrait vidéo qui
je te la chaleur
on va passer un extrait vidéo
d'un film qui s'appelle en page 2 en
page
et puis ça vous laissera le temps de
boire un p'tit coup il plie le regard
des
spectateurs
aura peut-être l'unique fois de votre
vie où vous aurez l'occasion d'entendre
une information dans censure et
[Musique]
messages
j'ai dû prendre la décision de faire
passer votre intérêt avant ma propre vie
je le fais d'abord pour vous pour que
vous vous réveillez et que vous changiez
mais avant de vous dire ce que j'attends
de vous je vais vous donner les faits et
ce sont vraiment les faits la msa
enregistre tous les coups de fil les
emails les textos sur la terre les gens
comme snowdon où assange qui nous donne
les infos nécessaires pour protéger la
démocratie sont traqués et persécuté par
le gouvernement des états unis ce
gouvernement a été fondée par les riches
intellectuelle infantile il s'assure que
le peuple est occupé à faire de l'argent
pour survivre qu'il s'occupe de sa
famille de sa maison de son jardin ils
veulent faire croire aux gens qu'ils
sont libres qu'ils ont le choix de faire
ce qu'ils veulent mais ils ne peuvent
pas les personnes qui vous représente
sont payés pour que vous restiez dans
votre bêtise dans votre petit monde bien
fermé sur lui même
comment se fait-il qu'ils aient pas de
législation sur les armes à feu alors
qu'il ya un massacre tous les mois aux
etats unis il y à onze mille morts par
armes à feu tous les ans en angleterre
seulement 3 100 pourquoi parce qu en
angleterre
ils n'ont pas d'armes les gens ne
possède pas d'armes point à la ligne ce
que j'ai fait par le passé et ce que je
suis en train de faire n'est qu'une
conséquence de l'absence de législation
on ne vérifie même pas les antécédents
des clients pour savoir s'ils ont un
passé criminel
simplement parce que 50% des sénateurs
sont payés par les marchands d'armes
alors réveillez vous
et l'assurance maladie
elle bénéficierait à 90% de la
population américaine pour faire simple
tous les pays développés l'ont déjà est
presque 50% des américains sont contre
parce que le lavage de cerveau
médiatique fonctionne à merveille la
guerre en irak était criminel bush
cheney et rumsfeld a menti aux nations
unies et au reste du monde saddam
n'avait pas d'armes de destruction
massive et n'avait rien à voir avec al
qaïda nous savons que nos amis saoudiens
ont financé les attaques du 11 septembre
mais à cause de leur pétrole ne faisons
rien contre eux à la place nous avons
envoyé nos soldats se faire tuer dans
des pays qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
terrorisme intérieur pourquoi obama n'a
pas fait juge et le gouvernement bush
bush a coûté des centaines de milliards
aux contribuables et a commis des crimes
de guerre
pourquoi obama n'at-il entrepris aucune
action justice parce qu'ils sont tous
les deux membres du même club
le plus d'immigrés renvoyé sous son
gouvernement que sous n'importe quel
autre présidence pourquoi n'at-il pas
fermer guantanamo où des prisonniers
sont enfermés sans avoir eu droit à
aucun procès sans aucune preuve depuis
maintenant treize ans il n'a pas mis son
véto à l'approvisionnement des détenus
dans le national defence autorisation
actes ce qui en clair permet la
détention infinie et sans procès
américain y compris nous avons une crise
constitutionnelle
aux etats unis nous avons un état voyou
un état qui viole toutes les lois
internationales qui violent la magna
carta charte qui définit depuis 800 ans
que nous appelons justice obama devrait
être jugé pour ça ils devraient aller en
prison les prisons justement
aux etats unis nous sommes 5 % de la
population mondiale et nous avons 25 %
de la population carcérale mondiale les
gens vont en prison pour 10 grammes de
cocaïne la moitié des prisonniers étant
fermée pour détention de drogue et la
très grande majorité est noir
pourquoi cette situation absurde de
rester inchangés je vais vous le dire
parce que washington reçoit de l'argent
du lobby des prisons pour ça bouge pas
pourquoi les pommes star les célébrités
les courtiers tous les jours pleins de
fric qui se gavent de gogo et des guides
à longueur de journée vous jamais en
prison parce que quand vous êtes plein
aux as vous êtes au dessus des lois
regardez lincoln le film de spielberg et
vous croirais que la guerre civile a eu
lieu pour libérer les esclaves comme
quoi le milliardaire spielberg pour
encore plus bête et ils feront sorte de
projeter le film dans les écoles de le
diffuser à la télé en boucle porte
toujours mais et la vérité c'est que
toutes les guerres ont eu lieu pour le
fric et que le petit peuple doit crever
parce que les élites en ont décidé ainsi
vous regardez la télé réalité tous les
jours pour tuer le temps et vous croyez
que vous êtes à la page parce que vous
regardez anderson cooper et d'autres
coquille vide sans la moindre opinion
l'apparence est sans importance les
marques sont sans importance les drogues
sont sans importance tout a été créé
pour vous rendre et diot la presse libre
la télé les films hollywoodiens l'école
l'université la religion tout ça c'est
l'opium du peuple comme dirait karl marx
je vais vous ouvrir les yeux pour
réveiller vos changer tu sûr que jusqu'à
un certain point tu aurais voulu être un
chantre de la vérité
pas vrai avant que tu sois intéressé par
le fric par la télévision je suis sûr
que tu aurais voulu être un vrai
journaliste
je suis un vrai journaliste
mais je crois aussi en l'ordre public et
je crois en la constitution la
constitution aucun mécanisme de contrôle
pour les riches l'ordre cette année ils
ont fait la constitution pour protéger
l'argent et les terres qu'ils ont volé
les riches non par grin dhr les lois et
c'est partout dans le monde regarde les
oligarques russes et les propriétaires
allemands de l'industrie automobile des
chemins de fer de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ils ont tous utilisé le
travail des esclaves sous hitler pas
vrai il est propriétaire de ces
entreprises sont toujours les mêmes la
couronne britannique
pas vrai et les nortier africains eux
ils massacrent leur propre peuple ils
empêchent leur pays de se développer on
lèche le cul des dirigeants arabes qui
viennent avec leurs pétrodollars acheter
des voitures de luxe à nos entreprises
américaines pendant que quotidiennement
il s'exécute leurs prisonniers il
s'accorde aucun droit aux femmes et
tuent les gays seulement ça on s'en fout
royalement parce qu'ils ont le pognon
nos grands patrons ne sont des gangsters
en costume à rayures et se foutent
complètement du régime des lois ils ont
mis en place le plus sophistiqué des
systèmes de sécurité intérieure de
l'histoire de l'humanité ils ont violé
les plus basiques de nos droits
constitutionnels et nos libertés civiles
ils ont détourné les ministères du
gouvernement en filiale de leur propre
entreprise et se sont emparés du système
de contrôle de l'information pour
saturer les ondes de mensonges dont une
est un bon contributeurs type tu n'es
pas différent des autres journalistes
tous les présentateurs de journaux sont
dans la poche de quelques records
il nous reste 10 minutes je vais donner
l'appui la parole à pierre connaissez
pas ce qu'il doit nous abandonner dans
10 minutes et pierre écouté beaucoup de
choses dans ce film
mais qui renvoie autant à nos propres
structures de penser qu on voit la
responsabilité des journalistes le is it
l'exemple d'obama par exemple c'est vrai
qu'on est dans cette situation
extraordinaire on veut faire passer les
chefs d'état africains devant la cour
pénale internationale
mais évidemment personne n'a décidé de
prendre mettre un embargo sur les états
unis à cause de l'invasion de l'irak on
peut le faire pour poutine pour
l'ukraine mais pas pour les états unis
la démocratie elle-même américaine
elle-même a obligé clinton faire des
excuses publiques parce qu'il s'était
fait faire une pipe par une stagiaire
mais pas george bush qui a déclenché une
guerre illégale donc on est dans ce
système là qu'ils acceptent
l'inacceptable ça c'est formidable
deuxième remarque ou là je reviens aussi
bien la responsabilité journal sur la
responsabilité d écrire guantanamo ça
s'appelle bon effectivement c'est
arrêter des gens les mettre sous
détention ne peut alors accordé les
droits de la défense ne parle pas le
permettre de voir leur famille ni
l'heure ni avocat bon dans un autre pays
ça s'appellera un kidnapping en colombie
s'appellera kidnapping en un moyen
orient on appellerait ça une enlèvement
pour islamistes
c'est la même chose mais dans un cas on
va expliquer que c'est un déni de droit
dans l'autre camp explique est un
kidnapping criminelle et dans le
troisième corps expliqué que c'est les
islamistes pourtant c'est le même
processus donc si tu veux arriver de
temps en temps à remettre la démocratie
selon les mêmes bases de jugement que
les autres c'est un travail de
perpétuels interrogations sur la façon
dont ces systèmes fonctionnent parce que
la barrière réglé dans la censure même
dans la tête des gens c'est à dire on se
dit oui mais chez nous les droits sont
respectés ces droits sont respectés mais
effectivement tu prends le patriot act
tous les droits américains sont
respectés les droits des autres qui le
sont pas c'est à dire le fait que l'on
peut écouter la planète entière on peut
écouter le chancelier allemand peut
écouter si on peut écouter ça ça c'est
un n'est pas illégal aux états unis
alors là où on va arriver aujourd'hui
moi je pense est un exemple qui peut
être cocasse les saoudiens viennent de
lancer un appel à candidatures pour eux
parce qu'ils veulent recruter huit
bourreau bon si un jeune type ce qui lui
plaît c'est de décapiter pourquoi il va
partir à l'état islamique pour michele
en arabie saoudite il peut décapité
légalement
d'accord et donc est ce qui serait
pénalement responsable dans le droit
français tu voi ambiguïté c'est à dire
est ce que le type on va le punir parce
qu'il est allé faire sa décapitation
légale en arabie saoudite par contre il
légua la dèche voilà tu danses est dans
cet état d'esprit eric
je suis sûr que c'est bof moi j'aurais
tendance à relativiser ce qui est vrai
ça correspond quand même parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de d'un certain nombre de
formes de terrorisme il faut pas oublier
qu'en ce moment aux etats-unis une forme
de terrorisme d'extrême droite très
proche des tea party très obama qui est
assez inquiétant qui est avec des
sabotages régulier d'installation
électrique enfin bref
puisque l'événement d'hier n'est qu'il a
limité la partie visible de ce qui se
passe aux etats-unis il ya une
radicalisation
extrêmement inquiétantes notamment dans
tout club le sud des états américains
maintenant je pense que
bondy la démocratie c'est très bien mais
je pense que l'on peut pas avoir un état
fort et une démocratie forte c'est elle
et pas respectueux de ses citoyens et
1er des respects s'est assurée que sur
un citoyen avait est capable de
développer un esprit critique et je
reste persuadé que la culture
l'éducation et le maintien de cet esprit
de citoyenneté d'esprit critique voire
de résistance parce que au sens premier
du terme et a été oubliée une par nos
politiques alors ces je pense que c'est
alors je vais pas dire le premier des
crimes et leurs premiers de leur faute
une faute grave a certes ça les arrange
peut-être il est plus facile de gérer
des consommateurs et des citoyens mais
je pense que ça ce prix là qu'on va
peut-être préserver notre démocratie il
faut pas que ça dure est un mot galvaudé
je pense que ça se construit tous les
jours moi je me souviens j'avais un je
faisais une intervention à sciences po
où un jeune l'expliquer mais monsieur
vous n'avez rien compris parce qu'en fin
de compte si nos parents et nos grands
parents ont fait des sacrifices et pour
qu'on n'ait plus à en faire ce jeune là
en gros pensait comme un consommateur ça
y est maintenant je dis maintenant la
liberté se défend tous les jours vous
aurez à la défendre pour vos parents
pour vos enfants et c'est une chaîne
sans fin donc c'est un combat de tous
les jours il est sûr que sur lobotomise
les gens ils vont résonner là bas je
vais profiter du dernier apple ou
dernier truc maintenant je peux vivre ça
ça n'existe pas c'est un mythe donc faut
développer cet esprit civique faut
développer la culture faut développer
l'esprit critique et la démocratie ne
retrouvera que grandi parce qu'encore
une fois nos hommes politiques ont
besoin d'un peuple intelligent
hervé précisément
ce qui à de redoutables dans ce que tu
as montré là c'est l'absence d'esprit
critique c'est à dire le dit parlent et
ils dénoncent tous les maux de la terre
parce qu'il en a l'explication il sait
comment ça marche et donc qu'ils donnent
les clés l'éclair en gros c'est le
pognon on voit deux et le côté
pourriture mondiale planétaire
à la sortie de sa qu'est-ce qu'on fait
bien on va à l'armurerie du coin ou ou
chez le dealer on prend le flinguer on
est en butte
c'est pour moi cette forme
d'appropriation de discours de vérité
totale qui englobe tout est précisément
mon défi
il est en train de me dire surtout qu
parce que si jamais toi tu continues à
ne pas reconquérir la confiance des gens
moi j'ai un discours tout près ce sera
lui c'est mon ennemi et ça je ne peux
pas l'accepter c'est lui qui me renvoie
le défi quotidien dont tu parles eric
dont tu parles et c'est contre ça que je
m'inscris radicalement pour le coup pour
utiliser un mot qui est très galvaudé
actuellement et donc oui il est en train
de m'encourager pluie mesure dessus et
plus moi j'ai envie effectivement de
faire une information qui est toujours
plus offensives toujours plus incisive
toujours plus arides toujours plus
difficile toujours plus exigeante
pierre je dois te le fais dans six
minutes on va finir l'émission tous
ensemble
je vais vous demander à vous trois un
conseil pour les jeunes générations une
préconisation
vous voulez quoi vous avez six minutes
donc ça fait 2 minutes chacun vous
démerdez vous pierre
moi je dis si tu veux je ne je n'entre
pas dans le l'idée d'une espèce de 1
d'état qui serait un espèce de monstre
un léviathan en perpétuelle gain de sur
l'espace de liberté des citoyens ce qui
est la caractéristique de la démocratie
c'est que par nature on n'est pas
d'accord c'est à dire que la loi sur
l'enseignement fassent l'objet de
critiques ou qui sauve son objet de
défenseurs me paraît la baule le
processus sein de la démocratie qu'on
ait des journalistes soient accusés
comme s'ils étaient des instruments du
pouvoir est un excès de langage qui
suppose qu'on ne connaît pas le métier
qu'on dise tout à coup quand on n'a
jamais fait de renseignements mais on a
des services d'enseignement qui sont
nulles et cetera venant de gens qui sont
des élus politiques si tu veux ce maudit
bon effectivement c'est comme si tu
demandais de juger un match de football
par un mec qui sait même pas quand on
connaît même pas les règles donc tous
ces processus là ne me gêne pas
on est orné effectivement dans un
système où aujourd'hui je trouve que la
démocratie est contestée par le fait que
notre liberté d'expression est contestée
par des gens qui nient cette possibilité
de liberté d'expression c'est ce que
disait woody allen isère la liberté
d'expression s'est pas donné le même
temps de parole à hitler et au sein d'un
des leurs à une victime de leurs droits
est aujourd'hui on est piégé par le fait
qu'on a un discours sur la défense des
libertés qui va couvrir également les
salafistes j'ai entendu hier un débat
sur quelle radio ou le type expliqué que
ça servait à rien de fermer des mosquées
salafistes le type n'y connais
strictement rien parce que effectivement
c'est quand même un foyer dans lequel on
diffuse une idéologie mais alors qui
elle est complètement décérébrant tôt
possible et on va expliquer que ceux de
les gosses vont en sortir antisémite ou
en sortir avec l'idée que tous les
mécréants mecs peuvent être massacrés
légalement et c'est donc il faut faire
très attention avec la thématique de
défense des libertés parce qu'on se bat
contre un ventre mou qui est l'état
alors qu'il ya un adversaire qui est dur
et c'est sur celui là qu'il faut
focaliser leurs gardes eric moi je
devrais redevenez citoyens parce que
c'est l'inculture de dèche ne fait que
répondre à un culture américaine
effectivement à ce qui me sidère ce qui
me sidère c'est qu'on va vers
d un nouvel âge de ténèbres vers et de
l'inculture et je pense que les jeunes
doivent se réapproprier l'histoire
doivent réfléchir veut redevenir des
citoyens au total c'est la base de la
formation des islamistes parce qu'ils
réapprennent leur propre histoire
totalement à mythifier mais d'un seul
coup ils ont à tout un logiciel de
défense à la culture la culture et
connaître les autres cultures c'est la
culture avec un grand c c'est à dire
l'esprit critique on peut pas faire de
culture sans être critique parce que ce
que l'on apprend il faut déjà comparé
avec d'autres choses et la culture
comparer en particulier très
intéressantes comme ailleurs à penser
unis je veux dire on oublie que une
période très démocratique c'était quand
même la dynastie des omeyyades où il y
avait les peuples levantin est un
exemple d'harmonie entre différentes
religions parce que c'était des peuples
cultivé
et on ne pourra pas s'en sortir si on ne
revient pas c'est vers cet esprit
sérieux se cultiver à avoir cet esprit
critique et surtout se comporter en
citoyen hervé m'a donc l'idée c'est tu
vois quand même la différence quand tu
sors de ça qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas
pas chez gastinne renette prendre le
flingue tu parles ordi et appuyez sur
search et est appuyé un max parce que tu
comprends parce que ce qui est
absolument génial et c'est pour ça que
moi je fais confiance au temps qui sont
ceux ci qui sont ceux du numérique c'est
que la confrontation d idées l est là
avec juste un warning écrit si un mec se
présente en disant je vais tout vous
expliquer à ce moment-là tueur appuyé
sur search et tu le zap c'est la seule
chose que je souhaite dire y compris moi
si vous avez le sentiment que le mec est
en train de vous dire c'est ça la vérité
pape tu changes et tu surf pour le plus
grand plaisir de l'intelligence des gens
parce que ça c'est un méga plaisir c'est
un grand plaisir que de se dire tiens ya
ça tiens il ya ça le plaisir de cette
découverte c'est le plaisir des hommes
de la vérité contradictoires absolument
le culture humaniste exactement var est
plus là ce sera le mot de la fin je vous
souhaite
une excellente journée merci messieurs
merci merci
[Musique]
le
là
[Musique]